the raiders made a move tonight it was
swift and succinct sports director chris
matthews has more on the reaction from
the team chris well thank you brian
earlier today the raiders released a
statement at the end of that statement
it said they were gathering information
and would have no further comment well
then at 8 50 tonight the raiders
released in another statement short and
simply to the point saying las vegas
raiders have released henry rugs now
this coming after the horrific and
tragic but preventable accident that
took the life of that young woman
raiders chaplain and former nfl star
randall cunningham says he's always
there for the players with whatever he
can provide especially with spiritual
guidance and counseling
what's happened it's a tragedy but we
just got to really be encouraging to
both families and yes he's got a little
girl so
you know as a pastor and as a chaplain
of the raiders i'm available to you know
just encourage him and encourage both
families
all right cunningham has worked out with
rugs and even attended his church
services the pastor also sending his
deepest condolences to the victims
families brian chris thank you henry
ruggs is the 26th player this year in
the nfl arrested that's according to a
usa today database